I just don't think you're ever going to
find anything that's going to recreate
the highs of like when you
knocked out your main tailor,
how the fuck could you recreate
that high? You can't, you can't.
That combination when you pin them in
the corner and put them away and then you
walk away and you realize that you won.
Oh Holy Shit.
And I don't even kicking us all going a
hundred miles an hour. You're up on that.
I see the pictures all the time.
Pull that up.
That would be with the
hands in the air and
people and you know that, that's
just, it was so fast. You know,
it took me
a while before I could,
I even know I walked out of my house and
I had them up, you know, on the side.
This was before I moved. I still live with
my parents at the time. And I did too.
I had a pulpit at the house and I'd be
leaving to go to the gym or something and
I look over at the boats and um,
well, you know what, those are my,
but it never really kicked in
until like a little while later.
Like those are my fucking belts.
You know, I did that, that I,
I'm the role champion and only I got one,
but I got three of them.
When you're lying in bed that night.
Okay.
You probably had to be going,
well, what am I in a fucking dream?
That's what it felt like it
is. What a fight this was.
God Damn, this was a fight.
This was one of my all time favorite
middleweight championship fights for sure.
And Jermaine Taylor, man,
he was a bad motherfucker.
He wasn't. And again, you know,
a lot of people talked about the
handful of ice before that and a tough,
you know, with smaller guys, but he
was a bronze Bellis who beat, you know,
Demand Bernard?
Huh?
There it is. Doom the combination
when you put them away too.
Fucking phenomenal man. Phenomenal.
This right here when you want.
She goes all bore. I just put
my hands up. Yup. Fuck man.
I mean what that feeling,
they try to describe that.
Like what is going through
your head? Everything. Right.
Possible for him not to get back up.
I know it sounds funny when people will
say that, but that's the truth. You know,
my big thing was if I got somebody hurt,
get them out because boxing
is dangerous. Right. You know,
and anything could happen at,
they could get back up,
they have a chance that knocking
you out or beaten you. So,
but when it was over, like what does that
feel like? It's, it's hard to explain.
It really is. You're just,
you're, you're on cloud nine,
you just not negative bring you
down. You know, you're, you're, uh,
you went from being a pretty dope,
I mean,
is through the roof to being
a world champion to being
a huge superstar unboxing.
Yeah.
And, and it's hard to grasp at once
and it takes time. And unfortunately,
sometimes you get it when it's too late,
you know what I mean?
You really grasp it. And it's just one
of them things. It's, you know, even,
I was talking with a guy
last night and he brought up,
he was originally from South
Korea and he was talking about,
he goes there all the time, big
business guy and he says, uh,
they actually studied my fight down or
something on how you could get knocked
down. This is more of, you know,
in your field of up your alley how you
get knocked down a what gets a guy to get
back up and recover to recovery.
The endurance to pretty much have your
brain's rattled but be able to come back
that strong Brown's later and
knock somebody out. You know?
And for me to simpler answer is, you
know, of course training hard, you know,
making sure I'm in shape. But I guess
what he's trying to figure out is like,
what's, what's the brainwave
pattern? Why? I said,
what's the m drive that
gets you to do that?
What does the endurance of
the muscles and you know,
that's pretty deep thinking and a little
pass. I think there's a lot there.
There's a lot and there's no one,
first of all,
every combination that you get hit
with is different. You know, some,
some combinations you're just not going
to get up from, and some of them you,
you were on the border. Can you get up?
Can you not get up how bad you want it?
Maybe think about your daughter,
maybe you think about your mom and you
just kept this burst of adrenaline and
you're like, fuck this, I'm getting up.
Yup. And the referee gives you the count.
He just fight smart and keep
your hands up and keep moving.
The next thing you know that cardio
kicks in and then you're back.